H
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS IN ORLANDO.
SEE YOU TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> Greg: HELLO, HAPPY MONDAY,
MY FRIENDS.
I HOPE YOU HAD A DELIGHTFUL
WEEKEND.
I DIDN'T.
BUT MY CAPTORS DID.
IT'S BIG NEWS IN THE TECH WORLD
AND BIGGER, BETTER NEWS FOR THE
MEDIA.
FIRST LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
GOOGLE.
IT IS A SEARCH ENGINE.
GOOGLE IT.
IT'S LAUNCHED AN INCLUSIVE
LANGUAGE FUNCTION DESIGNED TO
AVOID WORDS THAT MIGHT FIND
USERS.
IF YOU WERE TO TYPE IN THE WORLD
LANDLORD THE WARNING MIGHT POP
UP SAYING IT'S NOT INCLUSIVE TO
ALL READERS.
AND THEN GIVE SUGGESTIONS FOR
REPLACEMENTS LIKE PROPERTY OWNER
OR PROPRIETOR.
OR MR. FURLING.
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THAT WORD OFFENDS ANYONE.
LANDLORD GOES BACK TO FEUDAL
SYSTEMS OF THE MEDIEVAL PERIOD
AND THOSE PEOPLE ARE DEAD.
NOT ALL OF THEM.
IF YOU HAPPEN TO USE THE WORD
MANKIND, GOOGLE MIGHT ASK YOU TO
REPLACE THAT WITH HUMANKIND
WHICH SUCKS.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN SOMETHING
HISTORICAL LIKE JFK'S INAUGURAL
ADDRESS.
GOOGLE SUGGESTED ONE SHOULD
PLACE "FOR ALL MANKIND" TO "FOR
ALL HUMANKIND."
THEY ALL MUST BE TURNING OVER IN
THEIR GRAVES.
I WONDER IF THEY ARE PLANNING TO
CENSOR JFK'S "ASK WHAT YOU COULD
DO FOR YOUR COUNTRY LINE."
YOU NEED TO BLEACH HISTORY.
IT MEANS MAN OR WIFE HAS TO GO
BECAUSE IT'S IRONIC BECAUSE SOME
MEN ARE TRANSITIONING TO BE
WIVES AND SOME WIVES
TRANSITIONING TO BE MEN AND ALL
I WANT TO BE IS A WOODEN
CREATURE, A NANCE.
HOUSEWIFE'S STAY-AT-HOME SPOUSE.
POLICEMAN.
MANY COMPUTER SYSTEMS HAVE TOOLS
TO CORRECT GRAMMAR AND SPELLING
ALTHOUGH YOU WOULD KNOW THAT
AFTER READING JESSE'S BOOK.
WHAT STARTS ON SPREADSHEETS
COULD FIND ITS WAY TO YOUR
STREETS.
>> HELP, MY PURSE, SOMEONE STOP
THIS GUY.
>> GUY.
WE DON'T NEED TO BRING GENDERED
LANGUAGE IN.
>> I AM BEING MANHANDLED PRETTY
>> ALL THE MAN TALK.
>> IT WAS A GIFT FROM MY
LANDLORD.
>> IT IS PROPRIETOR OR PROPERTY
OWNER.
I DON'T WANT YOUR BAG ANYMORE.
IT'S WEIRD THAT YOUR LANDLORD
GIVES YOU STUFF.
>> Greg: SEEMS LIKE EVERY DAY
BIG BROTHER IS CLOSING IN.
COMING FROM ALL SIDES.
CREEPY JOURNALISTS.
EVEN FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA
CLAIMING THERE IS NO RIGHT TO
FREEDOM OF SPEECH ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
HE STILL THINKS TWITTER IS NO
DIFFERENT FROM EITHER MEDIA.
I HAVE NO OBLIGATION TO HAVE YOU
ON MY SHOW, THAT'S OBVIOUS.
BUT KEEP YOU OFF TWITTER, THAT
REMOVES YOU FROM THE MODERN TOWN
SQUARE.
THE ONLY REASON TO CHEER THAT.
THAT'S PART OF THE BIG LIE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT BEING INCLUSIVE
AT ALL.
THIS IS ALREADY SOFTER THAN A
TUBE SOCK FILLED WITH ONIONS.
IT'S ABOUT EXCLUDING PEOPLE
WHOSE OPINIONS COUNTER YOURS.
IF THEY CAN CONTROL LANGUAGE
THEY CAN CONTROL FOX THEY WOULD
HAVE TO SPEND AS MUCH TIME
INDOCTRINATING YOUR KIDS.
WHO IS ASKING YOU TO CHANGE
PROBLEMATIC WORDS?
IT'S ALWAYS ONE SIDE.
I CAN BET YOU IT'S NO IMPARTIAL
SOURCE.
IT'S LIKELY SOMEONE NO ONE CAN
STAND.
CAN YOU IMAGINE HOW INSUFFERABLE
A PERSON WOULD HAVE TO BE TO GET
OFFENDED BY THESE WORDS?
I WOULD RATHER MARRY AMBER
HEARD.
WE CRITICIZE CHINA FOR THE
SOCIAL CRITICS BUT WE ARE
GETTING THERE.
YOUR BANK REJECTS A LOAN BECAUSE
YOU ARE AT A CHUMP RALLY.
BIG
BROTHER IS US.
THIS WOKENESS BUBBLES UP FROM
THE SAME PLACES.
ACADEMIA, TECH, MEDIA.
THEY INVENTED, SPREAD IT AND USE
IT TO DESTROY FREEDOM AND THEY
AGREE BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
WORDS ITS POWER.
CONTROL THE SPIGOTS OF STORIES
LIKE HUNTER'S LAPTOP.
NO WONDER THEY FLIPPED OUT OVER
ELON MUSK AND HIS GIANT BAG OF
MONEY.
HE REALIZED THE ONLY WAY TO STOP
THIS LOOMING BIG BROTHER, SORRY,
BIG SISTER, IS TO SUFFOCATE HER
WITH CASH.
I AM MOST DIE THAT WAY WHEN I
WAS STRIPPING.
HIS GOAL TO PROTECT NOT HIS
SPEECH OR YOUR SPEECH BUT ALL
SPEECH.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE WARY OF
PEOPLE FRIGHTENED BY THAT.
IT MEANS THEIR IDEAS ARE BAD AND
THEY WOULD RATHER SHIELD THEM
AND LABEL THE THOUGHTS
DISINFORMATION.
ISN'T THAT RIGHT, MR. OBAMA.
GOOD FOR MUSK IF HE BUYS
TWITTER.
HE HAS WRESTLED AWAY THE DRUG
THAT FUELS MOST OF OUR MEETING
AND HE MAY SAVE THE TOWN SQUARE
AND NOT JUST FOR HUMANKIND BUT
MANKIND TOO.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
YOU THINK HE LOOKS SHARP.
WAIT TILL YOU SEE THEM ON HIS
ELECTRIC SCOOTER.
RADIO AND PODCAST HOST
BUCK SEXTON.
HIS MOTTO IS VIV AND LET VIV.
VIVEK RAMASWAMY.
SHE IS LIKE THE MILK IN THE BACK
OF YOUR FRIDGE.
WHITE, COLD, READY TO EXPIRE.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
HE IS REQUIRED TO MAKE A BEEPING
NOISE WHEN BACKING UP.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK.
TYRUS.
ALL RIGHT, BUCK, IF THAT'S YOUR
REAL NAME AND UNFORTUNATELY IT
IS.
I HAVE YET TO MEET A SINGLE
PERSON UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL WHO
DEMANDS REPLACEMENT WORDS.
DO NOT I MEAN?
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S A WEIRD THING
THAT'S DONE BEHIND THE SCENES
WITH THREE PEOPLE.
>> IT STARTS IN PLACES WHERE THE
LEFT HAS TOTAL DOMINANCE.
IT STARTS ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE WORDS
THAT NOT ONLY WE ARE TOLD TO USE
BUT THAT ARE REAL WORDS.
TALKING ABOUT A PANSEXUAL CHILD.
PANSEXUAL.
EXPLAIN THAT.
THE BLUE CHECK BRIGADE WAS
SAYING HOW COULD HE NOT KNOW
WHAT THIS IS.
LOOK AT THINGS LIKE ON DOCUMENT
IN WHICH PEOPLE SAY INSTEAD OF
ILLEGAL ALIEN.
THEY HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
GETTING THEIR WAY WITH THIS
BECAUSE THEY ARE MANIACAL AND
THEY CONTROL THE SPIGOTS OF
INFORMATION.
MAYBE NOT AS MUCH ANYMORE.
>> Greg: BIG NEWS.
HUGE.
>> IS ENORMOUS WHAT HE COULD DO
FOR THEIR FUTURE.
STREAMING IS IN TROUBLE.
WE GET TO WATCH THE TWITTER
EMPLOYEES AND MELTDOWN.
THEY ARE TWEETING ABOUT.
THEY ARE CRYING SO UPSET.
THE RICHEST MAN IN THE WORLD WHO
HAS SINGLE-HANDEDLY BUILT TWO
AMAZING COMPANIES GOING TO BE
RUNNING THEIR COMPANY.
IF WE CAN ACCESS WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS.
IF WE LOOK BACK AT WHAT WAS DONE
TO HELP THE LEFT DOMINATE
CONVERSATIONS OVER MANY YEARS ON
TWITTER SHUT DOWN THINGS, I
THINK THEY ARE AS SCARED OF THAT
AS THEY ARE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
GOING FORWARD.
>> Greg: WHY THEY SUSPENDED
PEOPLE.
VIVEK, DO YOU KNOW ELON MUSK?
>> I WAS TALKING TO HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF.
COLLEGE FRIEND OF MINE.
>> Greg: BACK AT MY PLACE VERY
GOING TO HAVE DRINKS.
THIS IS YOUR INDUSTRY, YOUR
PLACE.
IT'S A CONFLUENCE OF THINGS FROM
THE WOKE TAKEOVER TO ELON
FIGHTING BACK.
>> I'M HAPPY TO SEE THEM TAKE
OVER.
THE HARD WORK STARTS NOW.
THERE ARE SOME REALLY HARD
CHALLENGES.
ELON HAS SAID HE DOESN'T WANT TO
SEE SPAM AND ANNOYING POST ON
HIS FEED.
HE'S RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO RUN A
FREE-SPEECH PLATFORM.
THESE ARE HARD QUESTIONS.
THERE IS ONE GOOD ANSWER.
GIVE THE POWER BACK TO THE USER.
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT SAY MY USER
EXPERIENCE THAT TWITTER WAS
BETTER WHEN I DIDN'T HAVE TO SEE
PORN OR IMAGES OR NAME-CALLING
OR OFFENSE.
MAYBE IF YOU WANT TO SEE THE
WORLD WITHOUT THAT, THEN OPT OUT
BUT GIVING JOYCE BACK TO THE
USERS.
IT'S WHAT SILICON VALLEY WAS
BUILT ON.
THEY SOMEHOW FORGOT THAT A LONG
WAY.
IF YOU'RE AN ADULT, YOU CAN SEE
YOURSELF.
>> Greg: THE THING IS THAT WAS
BEFORE THINGS WERE POLITICIZED.
ONCE POLITICS GETS INFECTED IT
TAKES OVER AND POISONS IT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR?
IT'S MONDAY.
>> IT IS MONDAY.
AFTER SUNDAY.
SPOON ONE OF THE BEST QUESTIONS.
>> RIVETING.
I THOUGHT I SHOULD CHANGE MY
NAME TO KAT.
USUALLY SHE IS LEFT GOING OKAY.
WHAT I FOUND INTERESTING SINCE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IT, HOW
MUCH THE PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE WAS CIRCLED
AROUND THAT AND SUDDENLY OUR
ALWAYS QUICK-WITTED PRESIDENT
WAS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
WAS GOING ON WITH PRIVATE
COMPANIES.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS PARTICULARLY
AMUSING.
JEN PSAKI WAS DROPPING A LOT OF
UMS AND UH ABOUT WATCHING IT
CLOSELY AND HOW MUCH DAMAGE HAS
BEEN DONE BY UNREGULATED
FREE-SPEECH.
I'M WONDERING.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING TO STEP IN OR MAKE IT
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ELON TO MAKE
ANY CHANGES AT ALL.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE BIG STORY.
I THINK THE BIG STORY WAS
BRET BAIER SAYING --
>> I HEARD IT.
>> OKAY, LISTEN.
HE DID THAT FOR ONE REASON.
DID YOU NOT HEAR THE END?
KAT IS GOING TO CRY.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
TRYING TO DIVIDE US.
WE GO AS A TEAM.
HE MESSAGED ME AFTERWARDS AND I
RESPONDED.
YES SOMETIME NEXT WEEK BUT DON'T
WORRY IT WILL BE A TYRUS AND
KAT TIMPF PODCAST SPECIAL.
>> I AM CAPABLE OF BEING HURT
AND HAPPY FOR YOU.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE BIG NEWS?
>> I AM SHOCKED THAT IT
HAPPENED.
>> I AM A NICE GUY.
>> Greg: NO, I MEAN ELON.
>> EVERYONE WAS TALKING ABOUT IT
COULD NEVER HAPPEN EVEN THOUGH
THAT'S WHAT YOU'D HAVE TO DO
UNLESS YOU REMIND --
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IT LIKE IT'S
THE END OF THE WORLD.
NOW THAT'S HAPPENED I THINK
PEOPLE ARE CALM HER.
HAVEN'T AS MUCH FREAK OUT.
TONIGHT MAY BE.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE THE OPEN
ALGORITHM IDEA I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
GASLIGHT YOU ALL THE TIME SAYING
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT EXISTS
AND THEY DON'T TWIST THINGS FOR
CERTAIN NARRATIVES BUT OBVIOUSLY
THEY DO OR THEY WOULDN'T BE
FREAKING OUT SO BAD.
>> LET'S BE REAL.
IF TWITTER DIED TOMORROW WOULD
BE THE END OF THE WORLD?
IT WOULDN'T.
WE WOULD ALL WAKE UP.
>> I WOULD SAY ALSO.
FIRE THE EMPLOYEES WHO WEREN'T
DOING A BUNCH OF WORK AND PAY
THE OTHER ONES TO LEAVE WHO
DISAGREE AND THEN THEY TEN
PEOPLE LEFT.
>> WE CAN GET AN EDIT BUTTON.
SOMEBODY WANT THINGS CLEANED UP.
IF I'M BEING FOLLOWED BY A
SUPERMODEL, I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW.
>> SHE IS NEVER REAL.
>> NOT EVEN TINKER BELL AND
WISHING UPON A STAR IS GOING TO
MAKE THAT BETTER.
>> Greg: U